all right Madame Marguerite yeah Madam
Marguerite um where are you from
originally I was born in Brooklyn New
York but my family is originally from uh
what's now considered Morocco hmm tell
me about your family
uh so my family uh we like I said I was
born in Brooklyn New York my family's
pretty good I got a couple of Brothers
uh my family is no longer with us now
but my mother in particular was very
very
supportive loving woman and you know
they were kind of interesting people
they had very uh diverse perspectives on
things I had an uncle who really
um
encouraged my imagination and
um yeah it was a I had a good I had a
good family
good childhood yeah yeah
very creative
oh I first of all I was um very
unconventional so that is something that
I've had with me my entire life and the
type of teenager that I was I was very
vocal and outspoken
um I was already doing all kinds of
activism by the time I was a teenager
I was very popular I was always sticking
up for people
um people called me the bully control in
high school
so yeah and uh you know pretty much
everything that I am now I really feel
like started to develop in my you know
early Adolescent and teenage years for
sure so tell me who you are now because
I'm it's a little unclear as to what you
do yeah so I'm Madam Marguerite I'm a
fetish specialist and I'm known as the
animal play Monarch so I am a
professional dominance and activist and
educator and and what I am most known
for is transforming people into their
inner animal and dressing them up and
and having them do activities as an
animal
people are into that yeah people are
very much into it so a client will come
to you and say I tell me how it a
typical scenario yeah so usually the
people that come to me are people that
are looking to uh
Escape social
standards and etiquettes and and things
like that and really just looking to
sort of
let loose and
um
let some of the parts of themselves that
have to be tamed and hidden and sort of
suppressed and and just let that out and
uh you know embody something that's
great you know
um there's a lot of people that do pet
play where they embody like a cat or a
dog and it's you know very uh sort of a
nurturing situation they throw a ball
and they capture it but then a lot of
the people that come to me
I don't limit them to cats and dogs you
know they could be a cheetah or a
gorilla or something and and I I get
down to who they really are and what
animal most identifies them and so it
gives them an opportunity to really take
a part of themselves and and really
glorify it because animals are
spectacular and they are very very
talented and and they're Superior to
people in a lot of ways so giving people
an opportunity to sort of reach down and
and
pull from our characteristics that maybe
they haven't explored in the past is
really really nice and it gives people
an outlet to you know be important and
glorious in this little world that we
create together can you give me an
example of of what your client might
yeah absolutely so I have
um I have a couple really good uh
instances that I could talk about I've
been given permission by the the people
that I had these scenes with to discuss
this but for instance I had one
gentleman who came to me and you know he
was very uh very insecure he wanted to
be a pig but he was very insecure about
his parents and his weight and just sort
of these sorts of things so I said you
know what
instead of being a pig just a regular
you know Pig and and
attaching all these negative things like
being sloppy and you know fat and just
dirty and all these things so why don't
we really take a look at what this
animal actually is and you know these
are very intelligent animals and so I
transformed him into a truffle hog and I
had him uh every all the furniture in
the space that we were in we were in a
dungeon I said everything is a tree and
truffles are found at the base of the
tree so I want you to find me Truffles
and if you don't find me enough truffles
then I'm Gonna Make You Into bacon
because this the story is I've got uh
you know I've got a farm and I've got
restaurants that want products for me so
I'm either going to give them truffles
or I'm going to give them bacon and and
what we find is going to be dependent on
you and I had them
you know search all over the space for
um
imaginary Truffles and you know it gave
me an opportunity to praise him for this
little
thing that you know was only happening
in our imaginations and it gave you know
it gave me an opportunity to explore my
creativity and say okay you know what
could I what can I do with this what
could I uh work with to make this this
person feel like yes all right I'm I'm a
pig but I'm still special and I'm
talented and I'm creative and have some
fun with it and he walked away feeling
really really great with that scene and
that was uh it was it was really nice to
watch and
is a sexual turn-on for him
speak to whether or not
these are sexual turn-ons for people
there are a lot of different reasons why
people uh come to me and I don't like to
assume their motivation I think that
it's a lot deeper than uh
you know just sexual uh feelings and
desires and and impulses I think that
there's which you know is not to say
that sexuality is not deep rooted but
there's a lot more to it there's a lot
of pressure on people from society and
there are a lot of people that don't
conform and just are not naturally built
for the way you know society says
everything's supposed to be there are
people that are not sure about their
gender and there are people that are
neurodivergent that don't really connect
with social etiquettes and uh picking up
on social cues and and things like that
so you know creating an environment for
people to
um you know explore
what life is like not having to be like
everybody else I think is uh more so the
attraction but you know uh sure I I'm
there I'm sure there are a lot of people
who also it is very sexually driven for
them you know getting into the uh Primal
headspace and you know a lot of times I
dress them up in in leather and I make
them look really nice and and as opposed
to furries that are completely clothed a
lot of times the people that come to me
are don't have a lot of clothes on and
are very naked so I'm sure that there's
some you know absolutely a sexual
attraction to it but there's a lot more
to it as well and a lot of times
um you know sex is is not
really what I would the term I would use
to describe uh some of the activities
and typically these
are these people who are have have high
level jobs and
yeah yeah perhaps have a lot of power
and control in their positions they do
have high power Jobs first of all uh
this this sort of thing is not cheap
okay and uh the sessions last a very
long time they I mean animal play
sessions really should take a few hours
you know one hour is not really enough
to get everything done to be you know
between the whole transformation and you
know getting them into the activity
getting them into the headspace and then
pulling them out of the headspace and
the activity so it is expensive so the
people that come to me do have high
power jobs and
one of the big appeals is you know you
have people that in their everyday lives
they're the only people making all the
decisions and they're the only ones that
are responsible for their own decisions
and uh sometimes it's feels good to
relinquish some power and let somebody
else uh take the wheel for a little
while and just tell you what to do and
tell you what you need to hear
how did you first get into this work
ah you know I think
um how did you discover that this was
even a thing yeah you know
um I I
that's an interesting question so
this the way I do animal play I
absolutely am the one who pioneered it
you know there were people that were
doing uh puppy play and Kitty play and
things like that but I'm really the one
that took it to the next level and
really created uh the environment that I
create so
um
I had a production company I was a
producer and uh
during my time working as a producer I
would bring a lot of clients to
different events and things like that
and I would host parties
and at these venues they would also have
uh like fetish parties and things like
that so a lot of the women that I was
working with to host my own parties to
entertain my clients with my production
company were also you know exotic
dancers and uh things like that and they
really enjoyed working with me
and I really enjoyed working with them
and they would always make jokes they
would suggest that I should do like
fetish work like Kink work join some of
the foot fetish parties they would tell
me to do so then one day I did it I
attended one of the foot fetish parties
and it was
um
it was incredible it was really uh
mind-blowing the people that I met and
how intelligent they were and I learned
so much about uh
foot fetish itself and so I always knew
that sexuality was a
huge thing that there was a lot to it
and a lot of layers to it and I
understood that there was deep-rooted
psychology and probably even genetics
having to do with uh sexuality but this
was really very much a confirmation for
me and it was a lot of fun so I started
doing that uh you know sort of as kind
of like a hobby less
less professional and more personal
and then
there was a superstorm Sandy affected my
business very heavily and gave me an
opportunity to you know sort of say okay
well maybe there's another career that I
should follow and so I started doing the
fetish work a little more regularly
and um
eventually moved to Los Angeles because
there was a a big Community here
enjoying the community here and and
that's uh that's how I started but how
did it Branch off into the animal
well I would host
um parties so I would have in my
personal life these role play parties
where everybody would come in character
and you know there'd be sort of like a
theme and a reason why everybody's there
like obviously I'm the host so I have
some sort of thing that I'm celebrating
with everybody and then I would have uh
some of my guests that will work very
personally with me do animal battles so
to give you uh an example I would have a
monkey and a hyena battle each other and
in order for the hyena to win he has to
rip the monkey's tail off and in order
for my monkey to win he had to Deck the
hyena in the face with like this
chocolate pudding it's supposed to be
like poo but it's actually chocolate
pudding and people loved it people loved
it
and
um Dr Susan block
caught wind of some of these parties and
invited me onto her show and then once
that happened a lot of other people
started noticing me and started noticing
what I was doing and I got involved with
uh you know conventions and things and I
was just always with my pets and so that
was really how it uh
it really came out of my personal life
it almost seems like it could be
therapeutic or probably is a form of
therapy for these
people that that can't really
release a lot of the pent up absolutely
stuff they had from work absolutely
absolutely it is definitely therapeutic
for them
um even just the transformation and
discovering themselves because uh
the things
the questions that I ask
are the types of questions that
allow people to really think about
themselves in a way that I they haven't
thought about themselves but it also
allows me to get a lot of information
uh based on what like wasn't said so
I'm able to really craft an environment
and a personality and identity based on
that person and sort of the things that
they are you know suppressing and don't
really get to explore so even just the
transformation learning about themselves
and viewing themselves as something
other than what they're used to and
being guided through it and just getting
into that headspace it's very
um it's almost like a trance
really
and like a lot of the other fetish
like the fetish people that I've
interviewed it seems like communication
is a key oh yeah key component in all
this yeah communication is definitely
key
um
getting people to talk about themselves
uh in an indirect way is very key
because it is role play so trying to you
know skirting the line of reality
talking about reality so that I get the
information that I need but then also
not breaking the fantasy is really an
art and that's a part of the challenge
that I really really
appreciate and enjoy but it's it's
really just amazing to see somebody just
melt into submission and just let the
scene take them away and let the fantasy
take them away and let their
imaginations really run wild and you
know embody whatever creature we turn
them into it's really really nice what
have you learned about the way that we
all live from this specialty yeah
I'm sure there's things you've learned
that a lot of us like yeah are not even
in touch with yeah there are a lot of
things that we do as people that are
arbitrary and unnecessary and we really
it's very interesting to me that
we could as people could be speaking the
same language and still misunderstand
each other and not be able to
communicate and I I think that's
interesting because in the animal world
you could take an elephant from India
and introduce
that elephant to
a lion in Africa and they understand
each other they could communicate just
fine
different animals different species
different parts of the world never
interacting with one another before and
the minute they interact with each other
they understand each other very well but
us as people
even if we're speaking the same language
coming from the same place we could
still have such a hard time
understanding each other and
communicating with one another so just
shedding shedding that and just being
Primal and instinctual and just
doing what our nervous systems tell us
to do and doing what our bodies tell us
to do and doing what
the core of who we are tells us what to
do instead of what Society is telling us
what to do you know how to stand how to
sit how to look how to talk please thank
you you know all these things when you
really get to it it's it's it's
unnatural
so
um seeing how liberating it is for
people to just
shed social etiquette and Society has
been
very enlightening for me do you think
we're all too repressed as especially
here in America I think so yeah for sure
um I just overall as as a species
there's pressures to conform to be
who we're supposed to be yeah yeah and
you know most of us are not first of all
I don't think any of us are designed to
live the way we do
um
and most of us really really struggle
with it you know people have there's a
lot of um mental health and and issues
and depression and uh you know people
have mood swings and people have anxiety
all kinds of things that make people
anxious
um probably a lot of these mental health
issues are caused by the
the lifestyle that we're supposed to be
living yeah I absolutely absolutely
there's a lot of pressure everybody has
to be just perfect and and you know the
the
idea of perfect and Perfection is
somebody else's interpretation somebody
else's imagination somebody imagined
what would be perfect the perfect way to
behave and the perfect way to look and
now all of us are supposed to conform to
that and it changes rapidly you know
um what's proper and what's improper
changes with every generation so that
constant having to keep up and keep up
it's you know it's it's very difficult
for uh most people even on a micro level
you know we don't always notice how much
stress and Trauma we're carrying with us
but when you do things like meditation
and therapy you start to realize like
wow there's a lot of there's a lot of
baggage here and um
a lot of that comes from the pressures
of society and and you know conforming
but what's the most surprising
thing you've seen somebody
want to reenact
um most unusual let's see
you know I don't really think that I
mean I think all of it is really unusual
I think just
um I think just in itself it's unusual
to
have the courage and to follow your
curiosity and uncover
um you know these layers I think that in
itself is unusual I don't see a lot of
uh
adults really indulging in this level of
Make-Believe you know indul you know
adults indulge in play for sure people
play sports and video games and things
like that but this is really
I mean it's very unusual to you know
embody a character and play Make Believe
with a bunch of other people and and you
know create an environments so I think
that's uh I think that's quite unusual
enough so you create like a little safe
place for them to explore these things
that yeah it doesn't really ever
see the light of day else yeah
absolutely yeah and sometimes we do go
in public I do have some I call them my
Elite pets uh because they accompany me
to performances
and events and they show their face in
public and they you know they're dressed
up like an animal for uh periods of time
and we do different skits and and things
so so yeah some of them do get to do it
in in public but again they're in
controlled environments you know I'm not
going to the supermarket with somebody
dressed like an alligator
but give me an example of one of the
more unusual
uh
interactions or sessions you've had yeah
so um I was at a play Party
and you know it was one of the first
time it was a play party that happened
pretty regularly I don't remember the
name of it but
um and there were a lot of other Doms
that were very excited that I was there
I was there for the first time and you
know they were all trying to uh impress
me with uh this one they were trying to
get this one gentleman to impress me
with how good of a dog he was
and this was really really great because
you know when I say that I'm able to
identify a person's inner animal this
was a great example of that so this guy
and again he's somebody that I I've you
know I've got his permission to talk
about this but he was they were telling
him be her dog be her dog be Madam
Marguerite's dog and he's going woof
woof
rough rough and just horrible dog bad
bad bad dog not not a dog at all very
obviously a man pretending to be a dog
doing a terrible job and then he came up
over here like right by my feet you know
he's on all fours and I looked at him
and everybody's making fun of him
because he's such a terrible dog and I
looked at him and I said
he's not a dog he's a frog and when I
said that it was like a light switch
went off this man came up
ribbit ribbit ribbit perfect perfect his
stance was like a frog I mean he his
hands were spread like their little toes
I mean and it was just it was perfect
and everybody you know really was blown
away by it because
instantaneously he went from doing a
horrible job as a dog to really
embodying this uh character as a frog
and he hopped around for the whole rest
of the night I had him do
um play games where we would throw
something and he would have to like hop
to it to see how far he could hop and I
mean it was just adorable we put him up
we lubed him up so he was like shiny and
wet I mean he riveted all day I had uh
popcorn that I held in my hand and he
was like you know uh grab it with his
tongue and it I mean it was just
absolutely adorable it was hilarious
um but it was a lot a lot of fun and it
was just amazing to see how I mean it
just connected I said he's a frog and he
just boom right into it and he uh still
plays as a frog to this day so
my little frog that's great my chorus
tree frog to be specific
what would you say is the most
interesting thing you've learned about
people from doing this kind of work
that people just really want to play
uh people want to play people people
um
don't want to be serious all the time
people don't want to be serious all the
time there's a lot of uh deep-rooted
psychology that people just completely
ignore to just sort of cope with life a
lot of our jobs require us to just be
somebody we're not yes for extended
periods yes yes for long extended
periods and that is um
uh it's difficult for people people need
a release people need time to have fun
and people need time to exercise our
minds
in a way that isn't just work but
exercise our minds
in a way that is fulfilling
creativity that's why things like music
are important and art painting drawing
sculpting whatever it is mute you know
uh playing an instrument whatever it is
creativity is very important because it
allows us to exercise a part of our mind
that you know is it really stimulated it
isn't really given space to be
stimulated once we leave childhood so I
think that's really
uh one of the biggest things that I've
learned about people
we're all still children yeah absolutely
right absolutely and if you look at
animals animals play until adulthood you
know I mean animals playing until until
they die really so you know and we are
animals okay so uh
no matter how much you want to put
Humanity above
other other animals and and life on
Earth we are animals we're not different
from them we have nervous systems and we
have instincts and our brains work the
same and our organs work the same and
it's just that we have morphed our
uh Lifestyles and and conditioning and
and
changed our behaviors to suit
you know superficial uh human things
that have nothing to do with nature and
and what we were born to do
all right Madame Marguerite thank you so
much for coming in
educating us a little bit
thank you very much and uh I hope you
guys have fun thank you very much this
is delightful thank you thank you very
much